i i stand corrected but after rookie one
there is a move b6 i've never be seen in
my life which does not mean it's not
good but it's a very interesting choice
by magnus to play b6 and immediately to
to develop his bishop to b7
so
yeah very interesting way of doing it
usually in this kind of
pause and sicilian timer i don't know
what to call it usually you have your
opponent on a6 and b5 right to have the
pawn on b b6 and a7 and have the bishop
on b7 it is quite unusual i must say
and of course it was a choice by magnus
so in order to
to make
firoza think
which which is a good strategy because
he has a ten minutes on the clock as
opposed to magnus is seven minutes so
and
i must say that i think magnus probably
won the opening battle because the white
is going to be moving back his bishop to
e2 or f1 f1 more probably and then black
can go b5 black and go knight g6 and i
think black has a wonderful game because
usually it's not so easy to develop your
bishop to b7
right
and uh normally
white hasn't kind of committed the king
to this the king side either
so quickly when you see these b6 ideas
um
so
no i i agree with you i think
what an unexpected b6 it's just like
that
well this is what magnus is fantastic at
you know he's one of the hardest working
gm's and his specialty it's just i
understand really that after b6y event
d4 and why not c3 the classical way of
of making this system c3d4
just kind of not so logical to me
but okay
okay do you know what they are doing
bishop f1 bishop f1 and we're expecting
are there any potential sacrifices on uh
he's just simplifying magnus is just oh
he's trying to kill the game okay now
he goes quickly and he wants to develop
to c5 very quickly or to e7 and just
castle as fast but awesome are there
kind of any potential ideas of the queen
moving and then a knight planting itself
yeah absolutely i think queen e3 i think
bishop e5 bishop c5
but now after 90 bishop e7 you have in
mind to go knight d5
which would be
strong enough right yeah
so this is why bishop e7 will uh not be
played and if you go bishop c5 and the
queen will swing to g
g3 and now bishop d4 can be an option or
uh
castle because after bishop h6 queen f6
can be a
counter attack
move yeah
but maybe after after castle e5
so let's see how magnus reacts on uh
queen e3 on queen e3 so a quick reminder
of the rules ali reza farouja has 10
minutes on the clock magnus carson has
just seven minutes the players have kept
the colors from when they originally
played the classical game he's fighting
for a
point and a half he wins or it's a draw
out for magnus so it's a draw then also
magnus takes one and a half point
and first will get only one
and
now magnus is spending time
he's under five minutes so actually
there is a
huge advantage in time for firoza
and
magnus knows it that first is extremely
fast very good let's play one of the
best in the world probably yeah these
days
and
we have bishop
bishop c5 queen g3 but i think it was a
kind of a mistake that magnus was
thinking so long
or it shows that he's somehow a little
bit unsure of himself so he wants to
make sure he wanted to double check that
after bishop c5 there is no concrete
huge
problems will be
happening yeah because the bishop on c5
stands very
well uh
on that day well
we perusia just decides to play e5
very committal move yeah e5 makes a lot
of sense he wants to go 1994 and then
there's always obviously bishop h6 and
also bishop h6 in there because queen f6
is not possible anymore and uh even
bishop g5 can be strong okay so magnus
lashes out with f5 f5 this is just i
wanted to say like this
okay what happens after pawn takes pawn
yeah this is going to be the move take
stakes
yes
and also kind of one mention about the
clocks is that there will be no
increments until
the players have reached move 41 and
then it will be one second increment per
move which is not that much time
actually it's not so easy for black no
because after he takes f6 he's thinking
again and he's already under four
minutes
yes
and there's not much of a choice
but he takes the right thinking with the
rook because it's threatening bishop f2
so
um
and how is the situation after
pinning i don't know i'm thinking now
i'm thinking what happens if bishop g5
that's what i was thinking so the idea
is after bishop takes
well black has to just uh no other
choice than to take but here black is
worse
because i think well rookie one rook d1
it's only one pawn for the exchange so
now it's a big question whether bishop
g5 is possible or not
because rook f2 seems to be a beautiful
move but after bishop d8 i don't see why
is it good there's a there's a
discovered check here right yeah but
it's only check
this coverage check somewhere okay so
black can go here and then but this
seems if i'm if you're going to lose the
exchange this one seems a better this is
a better
way of of sacrificing and look what we
have oh we have it on the board
wow okay bishop g5 rook f2
okay look what we have here on the world
well faruja obviously has to capture the
queen and this is what we are really
having here rook f3 king h1 rook g3
and now
bishop b6
he even takes that bone and the problem
is for like that after rook g5 knight e4
but what about rook c3 it's a blunder
yes
is it oh no because beef oh
rick b1 wow wow
these guys calculate so quickly
so wow okay so there was no option for
black and he took
on b6 h takes g3 bishop f2 capturing the
g3 pawn
wow things are happening so fast yeah
okay rookie rocky
i guess bishop g3
that's what i'm expecting of course it
would be a nice dream to play rook f6
and to play rook rook fade rook f6 and
checkmate but unfortunately for black
knight e4 would be strong reaction on
that so
things are not turning out so well for
black because after bishop g3 firoza
played knight e4 which is important
because immediately even knight c5
attacking the bishop and the phone so
black is pushed back to play to bishop
ca this is not good yeah and he just has
one pawn one pawn by the exchange the
problem is that he's not active actually
he went to passive play by playing
bishop c8
so of course now black wants to grab the
pawn on b2 so so i'm expecting to play
c3
or to play knight d3 yeah that's another
option
but
taking a look at the clock times
while farisha has uh four and a half
minutes magnus three minutes
well it's not so easy to convert his
advantage for white that's clear
rook d1 is also something
to play i think
because this is very important for white
that his knight on c5 and it pushed back
the bishop but white played c3 after all
d6 and now
knight black
might have to retreat well the question
is whether to a4 or to d3
kind of the b3 probably bishop f6 will
be the move
somehow it's good for black to keep the
bishop pair and it's also the bishop on
f6 controls
puts the difficulty for white to be able
to push his bones i think
it's not easy actually to win this
position with white because
he went knight e4 centralized his knight
kicked f7 so he's heading to e7 after
rook d1
e7 and this is what we are having on the
board and maybe rook two
this bishop on e5 is a key
key
player in this game it's holding it
together yeah later on d5 is something
black wants to do also rook b8 to put
pressure on the b5 for the moment the
bishop will stay on c8 i think or or
it's going to be moving to d7 i think
it's good to move it to d7 and then
that way still
g3 wants to activate his bishop through
bishop g2
and for now d5 after that white wants to
go knight c5 and the pawn isn't takeable
but then rule d5
so this is the exchange what firoza
wants to do in this position yeah that
would be a dream for black
for white you mean yeah for white sorry
yeah
yeah
yeah because it's very important to see
the activity of the pieces and this can
be very important for white
rook b8 is played there's reverse
suggesting it bishop g2 d5 so now the
question is where the knight is going to
move into g g
now it's gone to c5 c5 this is what i
thought that it's going to go there but
now
okay so you can't you can't uh move the
dark square bishop what about playing
king d6
because for now b4 is not really
possible because of bishop ah bishop c3
knight e4
oh yeah
so d6 b4 would be the movement king d6
is on the board
yeah
but after before what
magnus has in mind i don't know
maybe he wants to worry
maybe he blundered this move
a5 a3
clear things are speeding up and magnus
is under two minutes okay and i have to
tell you
it is move 30. so that means 10 more
moves until the players start getting
back one second second more
you never know
yeah
this bonus like they deserve it right
one second extra so it takes b4 rook a8
controlling the a file which uh can be
important looking for contact chances on
a3
so that that's where uh magnus is
looking for conte chance pinpointing out
the c3 weakness and also don't forget
that the g3 pawn is also there so the e5
bishop is the key yeah key key player
here still but so far there's no
danger because of
white playing knight to e4 check
yes
so the pawns are okay for the time being
and
it's it's it's very interesting how
magnus just eliminated and exchanged the
eight pawns and now he's looking for
kanto chance on a3
with his rook so for a moment it's not
i don't see how white is going to win
because if he would be moving away he
cannot move away because then already
it's takeable the
uh pawn okay
what happened what he gave a check e4
checking c7 and now and b5 b5 instead of
moving away his knight
takes and rook e4
look at this what is going on what genie
is this guy is yeah look firoza what
kind of move he found just two minutes
on his clock
and he found this incredible and it's
the real threat is not btx e6 the real
threat is rook c4 and also to capture
the bishop on e5 so he surprised magnus
quite a bit
by playing this move what a beautiful
it's a beautiful very effective what a
beautiful solution i mean rook e4 was a
surprise to magnus he goes in rook a3
this was obvious that this is the way he
wants to
save himself
so after rook c4 and i think rook c4
will be the move and after rook c3 rook
c1 is possible or to play rook takes c3
bishop c3 and white is not going to take
on c6 but
i think rook c
will be the stronger uh problem and this
is what we have on the board rook c4
rook c3
120
against
53
seconds and
move 35 so move 41 is when they get that
lovely one second increment
and
yes pharisa is certainly playing very
impressively very impressive
magnus after making that critical move
and five we have rook c3 bishop c3
on the board knight a7 of course magnus
is uh an amazing defender so he will not
give up until the very last moment okay
rook c3 king b6 very important that the
c6 square is defended and of course the
bishop on c8
so now let's see how
firoza will solve this problem bishop c6
hang on a second can you not play him
fortunately for black he cannot take
that because sorry can he not play
knight takes pawn
oh
and check and then third and turn the
chest yes but then king h2 king b5 rook
c7 and grabbing the pawn on g's on the
seventh rank so this probably is a lost
position okay but
black played e5 instead
so
let's see what happened he played e5
and uh what has happened
so he's played e5 and now the bishop
came to yeah right when king g1 bishop
f5 and he moved away with his bishop
because by now knight c6 capturing the
bishop was already a threat so now black
has to take
care about his knight because knight b5
is not possible to b3 pin
and
so black played g6
rook a3 no sorry g6 king f2 h5 trying to
stabilize the pawn structure over there
rook a3 now obviously the threat is rook
a6 jack pushing the king back
which just happened bishop e4
rook a6 king is king b7 rook e6 and it's
getting worse and verse 4 magnus because
the e5 pawn
is falling off and the knight on a7 is
exceptionally bad and uh the players are
really
speeding up and uh making the digital
board catch up with them um
because suddenly we have a whole load of
moves okay so we follow wow wow wow look
at this seven seconds one second what's
going on did he lose on time no no no
they're still going four seconds so i'm
changing sorry things are speeding up so
much what's going on
the players were on one second increment
it couldn't
firoza just uh it was a draw ran out of
time but it's a draw
this is the information we receive
well